welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the boys
spin-off gen B episode 4 the whole truth
which obviously is a play on words the
title of tech nights show where he tries
to find out the entire truth but also
refers to him in the truth about holes
seriously every time the word whole is
said this episode it is accompanied by a
very deliberate thoughtful pause I am
loving the show so let's dive into the
Easter eggs and the cool missable
details and everything about
television's Jason Ritter that we could
find out actually speaking of whole hes
we open on a shot from inside the hole
that Emma burrowed into the security
guard's brain in the woods at the end of
episode 3 Dr cardosa Who we saw sticking
a needle into Sam's spine in episode 2
is theorizing about what happened to the
poor dead Greg maybe Sam penetrated the
year canal with uh his member that's the
sum total of your searing Insight that
Sam scull Bob here okay this is Greg and
this won't be the last time this episode
that Dean Shetty brings up skull f there
are also holes punched into the walls of
Sam's room and the eyes of all the furry
Woodland creatures are scratched out
maybe Sam didn't like the fact that they
were always watching him they kind of
remind me of black noir's imaginary
Critter friends in the boys season 3 and
if you know how that all went down you
would find them creepy too meanwhile
Marie Jordan Andre and Kate find the
tracker that Andre gave Emma next to a
big hole in the ground it looks like a
meteor crashed here maybe Sam can jump
like ma does this actually turns out to
be true later on we see Sam jump away
exactly like mave does as the group
argues new rankings are released Andrew
overtakes Marie for number one with her
getting bumped down number two and if
you look closely you can see Mason
Finster number three this is a student
we haven't met yet but number four is
Tyler oppenheim the student Jordan was
hooking up with in episode three and who
we learned can walk through walls the
name oppenheim perhaps not to Dr
Manhattan a character who could among
pretty much every power walk through
walls and often walked around naked
meanwhile Jordan is still stuck
currently ranked fifth Jordan is wearing
a necklace that is half pearls half
chains perhaps a nod to their dual
genders they say turns out the school is
a manga health clinic but you
guys are going to get a green van and a
talking dog and solv it yes Joseph Mele
was a German doctor who performed
horrific experiments on aitz prisoners
during World War II green van talkie dog
obvious now to SC in that group's
Mystery Machine both the boys and genv
love making tongue and- cheek references
to other shows like episode one Justine
said so my guys that Innovative are
sending me for this limited series on VA
plus it's an elevated superhero Thing
Really a meditation on Grief told
through 70 years of sitcoms and Zach
brass is directing yeah a little dig at
w division which was a limited series on
Disney plus and was pretty much exactly
that except no Zack BR involved though
maybe not to Matt shakman who started as
like a TV actor turn director though
through gen V is the boys and Amazon
really in the rightful place to make fun
of what Disney plus is doing with
expanding its IP I mean the boys are
supposed to be making thought of like
the superhero Cinema genre and with Gen
V in having a spin-off show they're
basically becoming it but so far they
seem to be having a good sense of humor
about it all Sam and Emma hide out in
the Stardust Drive-In which before it
was shut down was showing you could see
that four-letter word and red Thunder
that is a movie starring soldier boy
that was a parody of films like Red Dawn
and Rambo 3 Sam tells Emma that she
looks a little bigger and she responds
by saying that she might have swallowed
some Greg when she would through his
head this reminds us of how her powers
work and also sets up the reveal at the
end that she can not only shrink and
then go back down to her usual size but
by gobbling down lots of food she can
grow big Emma is understandably shaken
by what she just did I killed that guy
what if he had kids this Echoes huy
pumping Starlight for information on
translucent after he blew him up on the
boys being horrified to hear that he had
a kid and that kid is actually Maverick
Marie's invisible ra who we saw in
season two of the boys at his dad's
funeral translucent said to me almost as
if he knew something was going to happen
he said hey homelander tell my some
Maverick that I love him Emma jumps off
the table and gives the classic
three-point superhero Landing pose no
black widow hair flip though notice
Emma's clothes have a plasticky look to
them whenever she is shrunk down costume
designer Laura Montgomery wanted to make
her small outfits look like doll clothes
so she played around with formed leather
and would create plastic versions of her
clothes so that they would hold their
shape when submerged in water so we meet
Tech Knight who actually was previously
mentioned on the boys as a soup who
rescued a woman but broke her spine in
the process he has a true crime
documentary show on vot plus called the
whole truth the intro has Moody music
computer generated fingerprints low
lighting Corners reports and other bits
of evidence in the style of those shows
like making a murderer you know but yes
when the title of the whole truth is
revealed the O slightly grows in shape
and in girth you know to make it easier
to you know Tech stands at the entrance
of a tunnel looking like the opening
shot of the brain hole that we saw
earlier but fans of the comics might
know where this is headed because Comics
Tech Knight AKA Richard Vernon didn't
really have super Powers he was just a
billionaire who created a high-tech suit
that allowed him to fight crime so kind
of like a cross between Batman and Iron
Man he was a member of payback but
developed a brain tumor that made him
want to Bone everything ultimately he
hallucinated saving the world by boning
an asteroid about to crash into the
Earth but in actuality none of that
happened and he died when a wheelbarrow
fell on him but the Gen V version of
tech Knight is a graduate of God you and
seems to have powers like shlock Holmes
specifically the Benedict Cumberbatch
version from the BBC series with the
extreme close-ups a skin ve popping out
dilating like he can pick up on cues
like how much adrenaline someone is
pumping out or how much their eyes
dilate to determine if they're lying and
he wears a trench coat on his show kind
of like the classic TV detectives like
Columbo there's another shot of statues
on the quad homelanders is once again
covered in graffiti after the genders
that just cleaned it off last time but
that empty statue is actually
translucent which you get a clear shot
of on the fake God youu website which is
so cool by the way you can take a
virtual campus tour check out soup merch
all kinds of other stuff Amazon isn't
paying us to say this I just think it's
cool that they created IT Tech Knight is
doing an episode of of his show on
Golden boy's death and he's known for
framing people for crimes so he's trying
to pin the tragedy on an interesting py
as he does his intro he can't help it
giggle like a 10-year-old this whole
case is a rabbit hole into the unknown
and I won't stop plunging its depths
until I
get no one is happy that he's on campus
least of all Dean Chetty who says iron
cast killed herself after being
interrogated by Tech Knight ironcast
actually made an appearance in the boys
presents diabolical and animated
spin-off series though not an episode
that's been deemed Cannon by Eric kpy in
that episode iron cast is killed when
the Great Wide Wonder flies through his
stomach and kills him we see Tech powers
in action I myself have nothing to hide
small bead of sweat on your brow
adrenaline seeping from your pores and
you're ovulating by the way you all know
that when the new rock stars overlords
Release Me From the blue dungeon I sleep
like a baby on my Helix mattress Bo you
might not know is that this year Helix
launched their newest and most high-end
collection yet the Helix Elite mattress
the Helix Elite collection includes six
different mattress models to combine
high-end luxury with personalized
Comfort tailored to your preferences
finding the perfect mattress can be
difficult but Helix sleep makes it so
easy you just take the quiz and Helix
finds the perfect mattress for you I
wanted a medium burm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool and I
got matched with the dusk Lux Helix
mattress Helix delivers mattresses right
to your door with free shipping in the
US the mattress comes rolled up in a box
and is super easy to set up yourself
Helix has a 100 night sleep trial so you
get more than 3 months to make sure that
you love your mattress Helix mattresses
have a 10-year warranty Helix even
offers financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night sleep is
never far away and now is a perfect time
to buy Helix has some secret flash sales
popping up throughout October so you can
go Elite without losing sleep over
paying too much I love my Helix mattress
and I think you would too so if you're
looking for a new bed check out Helix
sleep you can click the link below or go
to Helix sleep.com rockstars to get 20%
off your Helix mattress plus two free
pillows he says he's going to find
someone to blame for Golden Boy death
and destroy their life you're going to
blame an innocent student for Luke's
hysteria
oh I'm going to Johnny dab someone so
hard they're going to want to crawl into
a hole and die yeah at new rockars we're
all kind of like debating behind the
scenes what exactly this joke means it's
kind of not clear like is he saying he's
going to turn the public against someone
else the way like Johnny Depp's legal
team did against Amber herd but is it
the other way around saying Amber herd
made a p out of Johnny Depp I don't know
I think the joke kind of works either
way but I want to know from you in the
comments what you think he's referring
to oh my god did I just ask YouTube
comments to weigh in on Johnny Depp
versus Amber herd oops big mistake
probably and notice how Tech runs his
finger around the rim of a glass if you
notice every time in this episode he
finds something with an orph for S hole
he always runs his finger around it so
Andre tells Kate that his dad knows all
about the woods and says that when he
was a kid he'd watch his dad's movies to
try to copy a stance later on we
actually see him do that same hand
motion right before caving in the head
of his dad's statue which still has a
crotch hole from when Andre found the
tape left by Golden Boy in episode 2 too
meanwhile Rufus watches an episode of
the whole truth about sheoth an obvious
parody of She-Hulk she appears in the
boy comics and here She's accused of
crushing her lover which you could also
look into as another possible setup of
what Emma does at the end of this
episode goes really big and threatens to
crush someone she's into Marie asks
Rufus for help in finding Emma because
she heard he's a psychic but he actually
uses his phermones to essentially rufy
her definitely a bad guy power she wakes
up in rufus's dorm room with his dick
out and with span out ballets
true H plane and she discovers another
aspect of her powers she can control the
blood inside someone's body even when
she can't see it and God why does every
episode of the boys have to show this
hey you can see the boys and chv have
been trying to like reverse the long
history of like female nudity and take a
step beyond all the shirtless hunks the
MCU has made us look at but God ruus
becomes another in a long line of
characters in this universe to suffer
horrific wiener damage we definitely
cannot show it here on YouTube but you
know you'll never be able to unsee it ah
the boys genv shows you cannot watch on
your computer or your phone in public
also Rufus was likely still recovering
from that whole Jumanji thing back in
episode 2 Jumanji despite Dean Shetty
telling him to leave the top five alone
Tech Knight immediately interrogates
them on camera about Luke how long have
you been eating golden boy's
girlfriend's hole yeah seriously this
episode take a shot every time this guy
says the word hole there's a poster at
the drive-in for red Thunder 2 which has
the same design as red Thunder just with
a two SLA on it there are three films
apparently in the franchise Emma is now
back to her usual size and wearing a
Stardust Drive-In t-shirt that she no
doubt found in the back along with that
probably expired box of movie theater
candy she's eating Sam wears the dead
security guard Greg's jumpsuit which I
guess he had the presence of mind to
grab on his way out of the woods after
his killings free also can't be easy for
Emma who's still feeling guilt over
killing Greg Tech Knight is the special
guest at Marie superhero branding class
and he fingers the hole on the tape
dispenser why was that tape dispenser on
the desk if not to just get get him to
finger it he interrogates Marie and gets
her to admit that it was actually Jordan
who fought Golden Boy not her Tech tells
Dean chedy that he's going to pin Luke's
death on her instead of one of the
students and as he leaves he picks up
that bagel and we know what he's going
to do with that Bagel Hole later back at
the drive-in those are posters of soldja
boy Crimson CEST and polarity covering
the windows Sam psychosis manifests as a
children's show hosted by Jason Ritter
and a puppet of the deep can't run
forever you know yeah buddy they're
going to find you and hurt you again
just leave me alone own television's
Jason Ritter this is obviously a parody
of Sesame Street with a sign that says
NYC Avenue V for compound V or vot also
play on the musical Avenue Q a Broadway
show that SPS Sesame Street with live
actors interacting with puppets there's
also the letter K as in Gill Ritter
wears a Mr Rogers esque sweater the
cardigan buttoning down the center and
the Deep puppet has gills that talk
which even though it's felt du we saw a
real life version of the deep skills in
season 2 of the boys and they talked
when he was rolling on drugs
hallucinating a conversation with the
his gills and those gills were voiced by
Pat oswal Jason Ritter and the puppet
deep convinced Sam that he has to kill
Dr cardosa before he can hurt Emma
Jordan and Marie hook up while Maggie
Rogers want what
plays Emma bust in to tell them that Sam
has gone after cardosa Dr cardosa he
used to work with Brink I know where he
lives yeah the evidence seems to be
piling up that the brink definitely had
a lot to do with what was going on in
the woods and Dean chedy has Tech Knight
meet her in the literal Woods to tell
him that she knows about his whole truth
just like in the comics he has a brain
tumor and it's causing him to want to
bang everything with a hole and we see
the campus security footage of him with
a donut a vacuum cleaner a gas tank of a
Jeep a hole in a log a traffic cone and
bringing this episode Full Circle a
skull in Dean ched's office and we can
see her photo there on the bookshelf
yeah what is it with skulling she uses a
video to blackmail him into saying that
there was nothing suspicious about
Golden boy's death and he spots a hole
in a tree that looks a lot like the hole
in the meteor in the comics with this
case behind me I move on to the next
mystery to seek out the whole true uh
give me a few minutes alone please you
know his camera crew totally knows this
secret Sam breaks into cardo's house and
screams that none of them are real
they're all just puppets in the trailer
we saw a shot of a puppet getting its
head ripped off spinal cords still
attached so maybe this is how Sam sees
most people and it isn't just isolated
to the Deep puppet I think we might just
get a big puppet episode I'm very
excited the others show up to stop Sam
and Marie pulls out her knife which yes
I have to correct something it's not a
switchblade it's just a different kind
of knife but Emma stuffs her face with
spaghetti to get big and subdue Sam and
then we get this interesting Soprano's
finale style ending we're going to make
this right I promise we'll whatever this
is it doesn't look like Jordan or
Marie's room the effect is similar to
when Rufus made Marie black out earlier
and it seems like they wouldn't have
shown us that he could do that unless he
had something to do with this so maybe
he followed them here or he's working
for cardosa but I'm super curious to
find out what's up they made fun of w
division episode one and it does kind of
remind me of that weird creepy jump cut
edit that they did in W division episode
3 and we all thought like our Disney
plus stream was glitching but either way
we end this episode on Missy Elliot's
Work
It and Tech KN night figures out how to
work it in a bathroom hand dryer please
subscribe to all three channels in the
new rockstars Network new rockstars the
Deep dive in the break room and support
us by grabbing some merch at nerd. shop
you can follow me at eaos follow new
rockstars huge thanks to Gina iolo for
writing this script and I'll see you
next time everybody
[Music]
bye
n